you always up everybody mad the Ouija
here again and I do still exist I know
it's been quite a long time since I've
made a video and I do apologize about
that but I'm looking to be coming back
with some more Dark Souls lower content
for the second DLC for dark souls 3 the
last piece of dark full content that
from software is going to be putting out
so I am sorry for my lack content and I
know a lot of you subscribe to me and
we're expecting comes a hot dark full or
content so i do apologize about that I
didn't plan not make any more videos but
stuff happen so I'm planning on
definitely at least one lower video
before the dlc comes out in which i'm
going to explain kind of what I'm
thinking that the dlc is going to have
in it I'm assuming most of you guys have
seen the trailer and the images and all
that so I'm probably not going to make a
video about that stuff unless you guys
really want me to i don't think i have
any super special insight for it at the
moment but i do think that i'm going to
be putting another video concerning what
i think is going to happen in the dlc in
terms of story in terms of lower how
much we're going to get how much of a
satisfying ending we're going to get how
long or big i think the dlc is going to
be and all that stuff so yeah the deal
see you still a month out so i do have a
good amount of time to make videos about
it but i don't know where you guys want
other than that one video which i think
people appreciate so if you guys have
something specific that you guys want to
see for my channel p it dark souls or
anything else let me know leave a
comment and also leave this is the last
piece of dark souls content it's going
to be released I need to know what you
guys want me to do with the channel
moving forward from that if there are
other games that i can do similar lower
stuff and all that but i do plan to be
hidden up this dark souls content pretty
hot so again i apologize let's hope i
get better about not disappearing for
months on end and yeah let me know what
you guys want to see other than the
normal dog school stuff and it right now
all you're thinking about is the normal
darts with laura stuff and then let me
know about that thanks for watching this
little update video and i hope to see
you in my next video and i hope that
next video comes out
thank you